Expiration dates aren't
actually expiration dates.
Important information ahead
so you could eat more food.
Hey.
Everyone.
Laci Green here for D News.
A study published by Harvard
Law School says 90% of us
are throwing away food that's a
perfectly delicious and edible.
We think that food has
gone bad when it hasn't.
Even if it doesn't look or smell
bad, once the date has passed,
it gives us the
heebie-jeebies to eat it.
I know you've been there.
I've definitely been there.
If I eat this, this is going
to make me sick or kill me.
The problem is that this
expiration date-induced
paranoia results in
several billion pounds
of unnecessary food
waste every year.
The study points the finger
at America's hot mess
of a food labeling system.
There's no federally
binding system,
so every state and local
area has their own rules
and regulations.
And within that, there's
a ton of variability.
There are different regulations
for different areas,
for different
foods, which ends up
being inconsistent
and plain confusing.
Between "best by" and "sell
by" and "best if used before,"
how is an everyday
American supposed
to know what's
still safe to eat?
The thing about expiration
dates is that they can't ever
give an exact date that
something's going to go bad.
It's really variable.
And as for the current
labels, the "best by" label
indicates when the product
is in its peak freshness.
But even if it's not
fresh, that doesn't
mean you can't eat or drink it.
Sell by date, on the other
hand, is a guide for you,
but for the grocer.
It's the date that
the product should
be sold in order to get to
you while it's still fresh.
In general, using your eyes,
nose, and a little common sense
is a good idea.
Have your tomatoes gone wrinkly?
They're just a little
dehydrated, but probably not
going to kill you.
Have they decomposed
and gone mushy?
Well, I'm not sure I'd eat that.
But to be honest, I've
eaten a ton of expired crap
and I've never gotten sick
from it that I know of.
One of the scientists who
reviewed the study said
that in his 30 years of
studying food safety,
he's never seen any
illnesses break out from food
kept on the shelf or in the
fridge past its expiration date
as long as the food
was stored properly,
because like keeping meat
in the store wrapping
to avoid spreading bacteria
and making sure it doesn't leak
on other things in the
fridge, not putting things
like sour cream or yogurt back
into the original container
once you've taken
it out, not putting
in open cans in
the fridge-- these
are the kind of things
that go a long way
to keep you safe and healthy.
The researchers think
the food industry
should go a lot further, too.
They're advocating a clear
and consistent food labeling
system, regulated at
the federal level.
They want smart
labels that clearly
relay safety information.
And they want the
"sell by" dates
to be made invisible so that
customers don't get confused.
Not only is this a food safety
issue, but it's one of the ways
that we can prevent food waste.
And by preventing
food waste, we prevent
a lot of wasted labor,
natural resources,
and we lower our
already tremendous toll
on the environment.
So have you thrown out food
at the expiration date,
or do you eat with
your nose first?
Tell me about it down below
on the on the D News Facebook
page.
And I'll see you next time.